hey everyone how are you I was so
excited because today is the day that
we've all been waiting for it's the
release of the new iPhone 7 and of
course the one that I ordered was the
one that was highlighted and featured on
the keynote it's the jet black iPhone 7
plus 256 gig iPhone I couldn't be more
excited because this is the one that
they were really hyping up it was like
the one that's featured pretty much all
over the website so clearly it was the
one that I ordered and today is the
release day so today I'm going to unbox
it for you first things first we need
our unboxing knife so this one is it's
really special for today are you guys
ready here it is it's the iPhone 7 plus
and what's cool about this is it's a
black box and this is super rare so the
jet black version is the only one that
comes in this black box so it's pretty
cool and take a look at it before we
open it up yeah pretty incredible let's
put you down here
I'm so nervous okay this is what I've
been waiting for for so long it's just
got you open right around there
right around there this is completely
unnecessary because the little like the
little plastic thing I can clearly just
rip off with my fingers but I'm just
gonna open it just like this okay
open it up okay the plastic is off flip
it over take the top off
okay over here
the first thing that you'll see is just
some paperwork so we're gonna want to
throw that aside cuz I never need to see
that wow it's so shiny ah
oh my goodness it smells incredible it
smells like a brand new iPhone okay
should we take it out
I don't want to smudge it up so shiny I
just just afraid that I'm gonna get
fingerprints all over it that's one of
the biggest concerns with the jet black
finish and that's probably why most
people are gonna get the matte black
because you won't have to worry about
scratches or fingerprints okay let's
pick it up we'll be very very careful
okay Wow look at this can you believe it
flip it over I'll show you guys the back
and look how shiny it is can you guys
see how shiny this is definitely gonna
smudge as soon as we take off this
protective covering this is gonna be
smudged up with fingerprints left and
right so let's take off the back oh hey
flip over take off the front oh my
goodness Wow so the cool thing about the
new home button is since the phone isn't
on I can't even I can't even press down
on it that's cool here it is
look at this there's already
fingerprints on the back of it already
fingerprints this is brand new
right I'm doing whisper your prints oh
okay let's set this aside be very gentle
let's see what else is in the box I'm so
excited to see these lightning earpods
ear buds ear buds yes they're the ear
buds okay so left in the box we have the
ear buds so as you can see here on the
edge of these this is a lightning cable
and it's pretty crazy because this is
the first iPhone about 3.5 millimeter
jack so I'm gonna put these there I'm
going to plug in this so as you can see
it just fits in just like that so we're
not seeing a 3.5 millimeter jack it's
very strange
okay so we'll leave that there so our
headphones are now plugged in right here
is the lightning cable - 3.5 millimeter
jack
so this 3.5 millimeter jack just plugs
right into the bottom of your phone so
let me unplug those ear pods earbuds
take this up and this just goes in right
there at the bottom so you can plug in
your headphones I have any headphones
here I'll show you guys how this works
okay so here's my phone and here's the
lightning cable 3.5 millimeter jack
and this just goes right in here and
this cable
I just got it put it okay hold on a
second this is weird something twice
working
[Music]
hey I'm doing something wrong good right
there
sleep in five millimeter Jack the sister
by five this is through book I don't
understand why it's not
that's strange well either way those are
useless to me now yes I'll just take
this out put that there
set this down of course we have our
little power brick which is very
important if we need to charge your
phone and that's it there's nothing else
in the box
I was really looking forward to seeing
something else in the bar stool science
comparison to the iPhone success so
here's the success I want to take this
case off okay so this is the gold
version and as I said this here is the
jet black version so as you can see it's
super glossy it looks really good and
this is the matte gold version look at
this it looks almost identical but as
you can see here the antenna bands are
gone so it's a much cleaner look but of
course I think it's time to address the
elephant in the room look at a dull
cameras isn't this so cool like this is
what I'm extremely extremely looking
forward to because in the keynote
they're talking about DSLR quality
photos and now you can take those with
your phone you know what else you can do
with DSLR quality photos is you can
carry around the DSLR and then you can
import them to your phone and then you
can post one Instagram but now you won't
have to carry around a separate camera
because we've got this so the one is a
telephoto lens so you'll be able to zoom
in and get better shots but the other
one is just like pretty much what you're
used to on your previous camera phone
phone camera phone camera
let's boot this off and see what we can
see because I definitely want to try out
this camera for you guys so I can show
you the amazing quality
okay so let's turn it on it's booting up
oh gosh I do believe this whole set up
this takes forever
almost on done and there's the
homescreen looks incredible if you guys
have updated to iOS 10 on your other
film then it's gonna be pretty much the
same oh my gosh okay let's check out the
camera I'm gonna take my first photo
open it up hey let's take a picture of
you guys ready okay I'm gonna zoom in
wow it's so it's like super Chris Wow
okay I'm gonna take a take a selfie oh
man it's so it's so much faster I should
probably do a speed test that's a great
idea let me show you guys these photos
first
okay so here's one of the first photos
that I took it's a telephoto and as if
you guys so it's the camera and you can
tell it's incredible depth of field as
soon as they do release that software
update I think you'll be able to finally
do that sort of blur thing that they
talked about in the keynote right now it
still is it look here's this one with a
telephoto and there's the one with the
regular just the regular camera
telephoto regular
Wow it's cool I'm already noticing as
I'm turning it on it's a much different
pressure sensitivity to the previous
phone so it's something I think you guys
are gonna have to just kind of pick up
and really get to feel it because the
feeling is I don't know I'm sort of
getting that feedback that I'm not used
to on this phone so it's kind of like
it's giving you a little punch okay so
how many apps on here yet so I can't
really show you guys anything that's
that crazy but I would love to do a
speed test of turning them on both at
the same time and see which one's faster
ready okay they turned on about the same
so don't stop it's about the same as
well let me show you guys a size
comparison to the iPad so here it is I
mean the size is pretty much exactly
like the 6s hey those eggs okay now
we'll do a size comparison to get my pro
so here's the front one here's the
here's the back it's pretty cool it
really looks good I'm a little nervous
though about how shiny this is but I
definitely think that I'm gonna need a
case I'm gonna have to get a case for
sure unfortunately I wasn't able to get
a case the Apple Store yet because the
one that I wanted they didn't have so
it's fine I'll be patient I'll wait it's
not a big deal not upset or anything
like look at this it's so smudgy super
smudgy I usually do keep a case on my
phone so it's really not going to be
that big of a deal and it's been such a
long time since I've had a black phone
I'm usually real into the white face of
the phones and the back doesn't really
even matter because before I was
supposed to be getting a rose gold film
but all they had was a gold so this is
the one that I ended up getting but I
really never see it but the front of
this I always have a privacy screen on
it so it ends up making the front of the
screen look black anyway so at least
with that as soon as they update the
privacy screen for the 7 it'll at least
all blend in so yeah I am super excited
to try this out I can't wait to sync it
to my ceramic watch which I should be
getting here shortly
I can't wait it's in the mail I'm just
so glad that I'm getting both of the
items I ordered at midnight on the same
day of the release just today so I'm
gonna I guess I'm just gonna go charge
this up and I don't know I guess I'll
just go play with it a little and give
you guys my updates when uh you know
when I get a chance to use it a little
more it's really fast so I think it's
it's like I'm scrolling through these
four photos that I just took and it's
wow this is gonna be great I'll see the
force touch oh wow it's so much easier
for the force touch - it's like I just I
barely pressed down and it's so
responsive well let me know what you
guys think of the iPhone 7 plus did you
guys get yours today did you not get
yours today and yeah I'm pretty into it
so I look forward to probably not making
phone calls on it cuz I don't really
ever talk on the phone but I can't wait
to get more into this if you guys want
to see the video I posted that shows
some of my favorite iOS 10 features I
will put that link somewhere over here
or in the description or it'll be on a
card so it'll just pop up on one of
these sides I'll see you guys later hope
you enjoyed the video
Penn's battery is already dying
[Music]
gotta go plug it in the Apple Control
Center is all new the first thing you'll
notice is they change these top colors
Wi-Fi in the Bluetooth so they're now
colored I kind of I don't I'm not a huge
fan of the colors I kind of liked the
grayscale look it does sort of fit the
whole iOS 10 theme from here you have
access to your flashlight like always
this will take you quickly to